I'm going to suggest that actually the
best order to do this in the question is
not the order that's been provided I
think we should do Part B first okay so
what's the situation well I'm going to
first write down what I understand about
the situation and then we'll launch into
Part B and then I actually think B leads
into a and then C and then so on which
is
weird and not the way they landed it but
whatever okay so let's have a think
um I'm going to drop a table I'd love
you to draw this with me actually what
the table is going to help us to
understand
is how all of the different numbers in
the question relate to each other okay
so what I want to have a think about is
that there's many different
possibilities that we have to try and
keep together and rather than list them
they're actually related to each other
in a systematic way okay so what I want
to think about is uh let's let's have
these two different columns for what
actually happens whether a person's
actually sick which means they're
actually positive right or whether they
are actually negative
okay so I want to have a look at three
things in particular so there's the
total
and then there are the test results
right so there will be people who test
positive and there will be people who
test negative in both of these groups do
you agree okay so um for starters how
many people have a look at the question
What proportion do people actually get
the disease
[Music]
so that's this group here they're
actually positive regardless of what the
test says so that's one percent of the
population
and the other group is the 99
thankfully most people are healthy okay
but then when you have a look at the um
uh the tests results right this is
different so if you have a look at the
people who are actually positive
thankfully the test catches it most of
the time eighty percent of the time if
you're positive the test will be correct
and until you're positive so I might
just put a um where my colors go I might
just put a tick here right this is where
the test gets it right but that means 20
of the time it gets it wrong right it
tells you that you're negative but you
actually are sick right so that's not
very good right so I'll put a cross
there that's bad right
what about the people who aren't sick so
the people who are actually negative
what percentage of them get told that
they're positive
five percent
so that's pretty small but remember this
is a mismatch they're actually healthy
but they get told they're sick so this
is this is bad right thankfully the bad
numbers are small but you know some of
them are still quite considerable and
then obviously that leaves 95 percent
over here
all right now like I said we'll do
something a bit different we'll have a
look at Part B okay so they give you
this formula
um it's the um it's this one a
intersection b equals this
[Music]
okay now I need you to answer me really
honestly okay when you look at this do
you have any idea what that means
[Music]
yeah yeah which is totally fine
this is actually really important
because I learned this formula years and
years ago and I'm telling you right now
I remember looking at and saying I don't
know what it's really saying because I
can calculate it like I can know what
these numbers are and get an answer but
don't know what it means okay so I think
probably the best way for me to explain
what it means is actually to say what
this comes from
it's actually a re-arrangement of a
different formula that I hope will make
a bit more sense to you and also it's
important for the later Parts okay so
remember we're doing Part B at the
moment out of order okay
what I'm going to do is I know it's
going to look like who cares what's the
difference right but what I'm going to
do is I'm going to divide both sides of
this equation by this probability and
you'll see why in a second so I'm going
to go the probability of this equals
that probability
divided by
that probability now
on the board what have I done just a bit
of algebra right like do you agree I've
just divided both sides by this
why is this helpful okay
what this means is
what's the probability if
something happens given something else
that I know such as it's raining
if it's monsoon season that was the
example I gave you before okay well what
you want to do is you want to say
remember I told you before it's like oh
100 of the time it will be it will be
raining if I know it's monsoon season
right but it's not always monsoon season
yeah so just say for example you don't
have to write this part down but
suppose in Malaysia 50 days in the year
which actually is a lot for it to be
constantly raining 50 days in the year
is when it's um monsoon season right but
50 days like the probability of picking
a monsoon day is actually 50 out of 365.
that's the probability that it's monsoon
season okay and then I might say oh
what's the probability that it's raining
and monsoon season at the same time now
all of the Rainy Days might be in
monsoon season so there might be 50 of
them right and again that is a
probability so it's out of 365. now if
you have a look at this it's one
fraction one number divided by itself
that's why it's equal to one I'm like oh
it's guaranteed right so what you need
to know is how often does both of these
things happen together that's what that
that weird symbol in there
it basically means both of them at the
same time so do you remember when we
were looking at those Venn diagrams
before right so this actually means
intersection so it's both of the things
happening at the same time that's what
it's asking you right so it's like oh
here's rain here's monsoon
and just suppose it was they're all in
the overlap okay but then you also need
to know how many days are monsoon season
right so you need to know how big that
circle is and then those two things
relate to each other okay
so then if I know this is the basic way
that conditional probability works
this is the thing and this is the
condition right reigning if it's known
it's Monsoon you put these two fractions
together like this okay and all I do is
just multiply both sides by the
probability of that the condition and
then I get this okay so then how does
that relate to our question okay
I need to know what my a is and I need
to know what my B is and they are
different right like this is not a you
know how if you say ah what's three plus
five it doesn't matter whether you do
them in this order right but if I say
what's five take away three that that
does matter the order is important right
can you see here the A and the B the
order does matter because you divide
through by this and not the other one so
I've got to know which one's which so
look carefully at the question with me
read it
find the probability that a person tests
positive but does not have the disease
[Music]
a person tests positive
but does not have the disease what's the
condition
what's the condition and what's the
thing we want to find out
yeah it could so what is known in Part B
is
that they don't have the disease
can you see it says find the probability
that a person tests positive but does
not have the disease right so it's
actually known
that they are really healthy right but I
want to know what's the probability that
they test positive anyway does that make
sense
okay so if that's what the two pieces
are I just need to know what goes into
here right and we've actually already
written this up right
if you have a look my probability that
they're going to test positive
is this five percent number here do you
see that right it's five percent
um for them
testing positive
in this actual negative area right
but then I need to know well how many
people are going to be actually negative
right it's like how many Monsoon days
are there right can you tell me look
back at the table what's the probability
that you get if I randomly pick someone
I pick someone who is actually negative
well
it's actually this number up here you
see this so This 99 is a little bit like
how many Monsoon days are there
thankfully 99 out of 100 people are
healthy right so my probability of
getting one of these actually healthy
people is going to be 99 percent
right so therefore this probability five
percent times 99 I'm pretty sure that'll
give you
4.95 that's the actual answer okay
how's your brain going at the moment do
you have any questions about any of that
that's okay it is a bit weird like
um why we're multiplying these by one
another the way I like to think about it
is
um
first here's how many people you're
looking at because I know like I've got
to restrict myself to this 99 and then I
say well five percent of them are going
to have that test positive
um
favorable event favorable right I don't
want you to actually test positive but
that's that okay so now let me go to a
uh hopefully you'll see why I think the
order is weird right part A says what
percentage of this group would test
positive well I already have this part
of the group they test positive even
though they're healthy right so the
probability of testing positive it
happens in two ways right firstly
there's the people who test positive
but are actually negative
that's the one I just worked out right
there that's 4.95 percent
but then there's another group of people
who test positive who are they
the people who actually are positive
because I removed them from the group
when I was doing this right
um but thankfully I can work it out in
exactly the same way so remember how you
said okay
test positive
actually negative so I multiplied these
two numbers right I'm now going to go
over here and I'm going to say test
positive
actually positive right so 80 of them
will test positive but there's not very
many of them to begin with okay so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to have
this number here 4.95 percent
and what I'm going to add that to is
one percent of eighty percent or if you
want to think about it the other way
eighty percent of one percent which is
0.8 like that's just this multiplied by
that is that okay
so obviously you can pop that into your
calculator what is that 5.75
that's the percentage okay so can you
see why I thought it was weird that you
do a and then B afterwards because to
work out a you need to have worked out b
anyway weird textbook okay now we can
keep going and this is where it starts
to get really interesting the Bell is
going to go shortly but I think we can
get there okay
so part C says what's the probability of
a false positive okay now what does this
actually mean well
this is going to get to the conditional
probability fraction that I made here
before okay so what I want to know is
um this is the probability of and the
question even says it right it's
actually
negative
but it's known that the test
is positive
so this is me trying to use this
notation here okay all right now
we actually have already worked out some
bits of this right this actually
negative but test positive that's
actually
um that's actually related to this
number here right
these people are actually negative and
they've tested positive yes but they're
not the only people who have tested
positive so this is the fraction that I
need here right
the people who are the probability of
getting someone who's actually negative
or tested positive that was this part
here so that's
4.95 percent
but the probability of getting anyone
who tests positive remember there's the
other people who are actually positive
right so this group here in part A
that's all the people who test positive
this is the this is the B that should be
in the denominator so my denominator
should be
5.75 percent
so these are the people who are actually
negative and test positive and this is
all the people who are testing positive
whether they have it or not
um you can go and put that into your
calculator if you like I think you get
something like 86.1
percent or so okay
now okay I'm gonna be really cheeky
um
I kind of need to leave everything there
because I think it relates so I'm just
going to write party here okay this is
now the probability of a the other way
false negative
so this is about
you're actually positive
right like sorry you're sick but the
test tells you you're negative anyway
right so this is kind of the reverse of
everything that we did before so what I
need to do is I need to work out okay
instead of multiplying 5 times 99 these
are the people who test positive
I'm actually going to be multiplying 95
by 99 because I need them to I'm
interested in the people who are testing
negative does that make sense so
therefore what you're actually going to
get I'll I'll write it here for you so
you can follow it up later right
um this group here is that the top group
is one percent of
20 just have a look at where I got that
from right
these are the people who they're
actually positive
but they test negative right
this is a really bad situation right you
don't want to be really sick but then
told you're healthy because you'll be
like I'm fine I don't need treatment
that's a bad situation right so that's
why it's on my numerator
on the denominator I need to account for
everybody
who test negative which includes this
enormous group over here right so it
includes that one percent of 20 that I
just mentioned
but it also includes 99 of
95 because those people get told they're
negative as well I know you've tested
negative I just don't know which one you
are are you actually positive or
actually narrative I don't know that's
why I include both of them here okay you
can go ahead and you can work that out
thankfully this is not a very large
number it's about 2.1
percent